welcome back to another edition of The
Gadget Lab podcast I am Michael colori
I'm Christina Bonnington on today's show
we're going to talk a little bit about
the brand new apple tablet maybe you've
heard of it it's called the ipad and
then later on in the second half we're
gonna bring on Nathan her said he's
gonna show off some badass gadgets but
first and foremost you have in front of
you ipad 32 shd no just the ipad it's
just the ipad just ipad why do they call
it the ipad 3 that's a good question i
mean the macbook apple TV a whole bunch
of other lines don't have any sort of
number at the end of them so cuz i'm
just getting back to their roots just
the new one yeah so the big thing is
what the screen right is that the big
thing it is the big thing breton display
2048 x 1536 it looks very nice things
like Flipboard photographs what about HD
movies yeah yeah that's great too
watching video did you write did you
download the new episode of Mad Men off
a bit torrent and watch it in high
definition on your new iPad of course
not okay then you're doing it wrong um
but I guess that it really does sort of
raise raise the the question of like
what can Apple do next and right in our
review and in some of your coverage I
know that that question has been raised
because that was the big thing that
everybody was expecting well okay we
should yeah we should also say 4G and
the new camera yes which you know takes
better pictures but it doesn't make
taking pictures with an ipad any less
awkward right yeah you still look like a
jerk yeah holding up this dried dinner
tray taking snaps your kid run screaming
instead of smiling at you I think you're
gonna get hit um so the screen is as
sharp as the iphone for us now yeah just
about with the distance that you hold it
from your face they're both considered
retina display by Apple the pixel
density is actually a little bit less
but you hold an iPad
what is it 15 18 inches from your face
and I found you'd normally hold a little
bit closer 12 to 15 inches from your
face okay so perceptibly they're very
very similar yes um but functionally
there are it's it's a huge improvement
over the previous one yeah I mean it
looks nice i mean it's it's evolution
evolutionary not revolutionary what do
they say at the announcement resolution
resolution i got a lot of heat for that
it was pretty bad understandably but um
as far as the as far as the innovations
that they can put into the into the
device from now it's it's pretty limited
right yeah i mean we could see something
like haptic feedback you know so when
you touch it there's a little bit of
vibration I'm kind of like smartphones
that have that so you touch the keys and
you kind of feel that little bit of
feedback when you're typing yeah I like
it I know you you don't really care for
that so much right now no I prefer my
guys devices to be silent and non
vibrating unless I tell them to so I'm
sure you know if they were to put that
in to be something they would live would
let you turn off yeah I think it'll be
cool when there's embedded projectors in
our devices but I think that's still a
little ways down the road I mean I
embedded projectors that like so I can
like project something maybe a keyboard
onto a table and I can like type on that
oh ya think so it's like interactive
we've seen that we've seen people try to
do that and it's a it's been a failure
yeah yeah it's been pretty bad but i
mean the the point is you know next
year's ipad is probably not going to be
that much better than this ipad but
people will probably still rush out and
buy it because a little bit better is
just more desirable than you know last
year's model yeah although a lot of
people i talked to in the ipad line
we're actually upgrading from a first
gen ipad 2 3rd generation seems like a
lot of people that had the ipad 2 or
sticking it out for whatever next year
has to offer yeah leapfrogging people do
that with phones people do that with
laptops so it makes sense they would do
it with their tablets so what do you
think would you recommend that somebody
upgrade from a2 to a3 or from a one two
or three from a2 to a3
I mean if your Big Apple fan I'd say go
for it but otherwise you know I think
you'd be fine waiting for next year I
definitely recommend upgrading if you
have an iPad one if you have an original
iPad go ahead you can you can sell it
back to amazon for a hundred bucks or to
shave a little bit off the price give it
to the child in your life yes reuse it
give it to a teacher friends or just
keep it and remain a loser it's totally
up to you anyway thanks Christina you'll
probably be back next week with more
exciting apple news always there's
always exciting apple news on the gadget
lab show up next we're gonna bring on
Nathan hearse and he's going to show us
a flashlight and other things that can
kill you okay stop what is that thing
this is the LED lenser it is a
particularly bad ass flash light that
shines with a force of 1000 lumens 1000
lumens yes that's a lot it is a lot
although bowman's is kind of a funny
measurement because it doesn't account
for how focused a light is so there's
really no way to compare how bright this
is to to you know say like a car
headlight or something other than to say
it's just really bright it's about as
bright as a very very bright car
headlight I found that it's from trying
not to look directly at it that's about
what I've debated so this is uh how much
is something like that cost this
particular one is five hundred dollars
five hundred bucks and what does it hold
does it hold like a bunch of what's D
batteries or D batteries so they're easy
to replace how many four there's four in
here and seven very large LEDs on the
front that's cool so if those burnt out
you just swap men or um you know I don't
know if they're replaceable I know oh
yeah they must be four five hundred
dollars they better be yeah they better
be it's also it's got substantial weight
so you could like meet people if yeah
this is
really happy yeah so this is a kind of
thing that you would do probably like
you would take with you to a rock
concert if you're up in the nosebleeds
you know so you can see the stage a
little bit better maybe like sit behind
home plate during a baseball game and
flash it at the visiting pitcher they
might frown on that yeah maybe so this
is this is a is a badass item that it is
it's one of a number of badass items
we've been featuring on the gadget lab
blog you could do one a day's alright
I'm not quite one a day oh but quite
wanted a few weeks yep we'll have we'll
have three or four this week and one of
them is actually this this is our there
Gerber's MMP DET 600 DET multi-tool so
it's it's a pair of pliers with a c4
punch and when I choose which is what a
tool for preparing explosives yes well
when I first looked at it I didn't know
where that was I just wanted to give who
wouldn't want to punch c4 really so
that's what this part of the tool is
that sort of spiky pencil e looking
finish yes it's really quite vicious
yeah so other than that I mean it's also
just an amazing multi tool it's got you
know a bunch of different stuff for it
does is sawing through linds or you know
disemboweling rodents got a saw it's got
a knife it's got a pair of pliers it's
got you know your typical multi-tool
functions like screwdrivers and so on
yeah so speaking of sharp pencil e
pointing things you've got one of my
personal favorite badass gadgets for the
month in your pocket now it looks like a
pen it is a pen it is a pen however the
pen does not come out the pointy pen end
you actually have to unscrew it to get
to the pen the pointy pen end is sort of
like a kubaton or something it's
exacting it's basically useful for
gouging out somebody's eyeball yeah so I
didn't know this but it they call them
tactical pens and tactical pens are
actually a thing you carry them around
in your pocket in case you have to
defend yourself so you can go all Jason
Bourne on somebody right um and they're
made you know they're mostly made of a
pretty substantial a denies aluminum
this one in particular is made by Smith
& Wesson the gun people yes hahaha well
I suppose it's a good thing you know if
you really need like that old joke like
I can kill you with a ballpoint pen it's
a ball pen point pen made to kill people
with that's pretty awesome yeah so I
suspect that something that you take
with you whenever you go to the French
Laundry and maybe the Somali a
recommends a bottle of wine that you
find particularly offensive you can you
know give him a new hole in the neck or
something like that I wouldn't recommend
it oh you wouldn't recommend it okay
well okay between your giant flashlight
that can blind people your your your
tool multi tool that is also capable of
preparing anti-personnel mines and your
pen that can kill people yeah you might
want to stay away from me yes Curtis Lee
so what's coming up next on the on the
badass gadgets list anything you can
leak well um we have got we've got a
gaming mouse that is it's it's kind of a
deep orange it's all customizable and
kid is it weaponized bowl at all I mean
that seems to be the theme here not
really not really all right all right
watch something else um we're actually
trying to get away from the web weapons
yeah that's smart because we are we all
do practice non-violence here at Wired
we're we are not quite pacifists we do
believe that there are certain times
when violence is necessary self-defense
self-defense snooty Somali A's however
you know most of the time we prefer just
to do things like play video games and
make jokes about hurting people yes but
I really do I like to operate on the
principle of not that you could or not
that you should but you could but that
you could and on that note you should
join us next week for another edition of
The Gadget Lab show I'm Michael and I'm
Nathan see you next time